Kathy what's the difference between a
low and a high concept movie and which
one favors new writers I think that the
low concept favors new writers only
because I think studios in general are
more willing to take a chance on
something that maybe is lower in in
budget but concept and budget are two
different things a high concept movie
usually means a higher concept budget in
general and that would be like your
action pictures your hero superhero
pictures things like Star Wars things
that have what they call the tent pole
you've probably heard that that term
before a tent pole effect it's just it's
a lot different I don't think it's you
and most of them you'll notice are based
on something that's been adapted from
another piece of of material like comics
a book novels that kind of thing but for
new people coming in new writers coming
in writing a nice refreshing project
that's in another arena that's not
doesn't require a huge budget and a lot
of special effects that's the way to
really get a sense of can they develop
characters can they carry a story all
the way through front for 90 minutes to
100 minutes and can they can they give
us good roles that actors want so that I
think is better as if you try and do a
lower budget lower concept in terms of
genre or you know that's the way to do
it just reminder what's the definition
of high concept and low concept again
well high concept usually mean something
that is you can you can do a lot more
with it in terms of well they can always
be sequels or prequels those tend to be
more high budget and more high concept
in terms of it's a larger world more
characters and they can do like I said
more with it they can continue on an
adventure with all of those character
so that's why I think a lot of them
you'll see are adapted from other pieces
of material now what's a good test if
somebody thinks their script is
high-concept how can they kind of run it
through some tests because maybe they
find out it's actually low concept and
they're just not aware I think genre is
one way if you look at the ones that
usually make the most money or that are
based on other pieces of material a lot
of times they fall into science fiction
horror fantasy or siphon a see those are
the most popular genres for that
certainly if you look at things that are
action-adventure like The Bourne
Identity that's another one that you can
do a lot with because it's there's
always going to be a new adventure as
this guy is trying to find out his real
identity
you